This is going on today in China.
World Cup kiss sparks,
social media debate on sexual
harassment in China. Hello. Why? Uh,
so he's a male reporter
in these two Russian fans,
gave him a kiss while he was recording
and it's caused like a reverse sexual
harassment debate and transparently
it's a big deal. Wow. He looks so,
what's a big deal that in China,
someone like you're not allowed
to show public affection like fan.
Is that what the big debate is?
Here's the,
it came after a bunch of female
journalists have been assaulted and so,
so they started assaulting
the dude the other way around.
I'm going to go out on a limb. He's
going to be okay. He looks fine.
It looks actually better than kissed
on the cheek by attractive women. Um,
they're not hurting them. They can't
rape him. I think he's going to be okay.
Let's watch on boy get mauled
by these hot Russian broads.
Here it goes. Wow. Kiss.
Nope, nothing. Nothing.
He's fine. He's laughing. Okay. We're
done. He's laughing. We're done.
Stop. This. People are fucking crazy. The
guys laughing. He thought it was cute.
Yeah. Why would anybody make a deal
out of that? It's a zero tolerance.
That girl literally had a
plastic Red Cup in her hand,
which is the universal sign for
being fucked up in public. Yeah.
If you got that Plastic Red Cup in
your hand, that chick's probably lit.
She kissed that guy.
He thought it was cute.
They didn't move them around
or push them or assault him.
It was a friendly gesture on
the cheek. That's love. I think.
Why are we trying to shut down
people enjoying each other?
I don't think we are anymore.
I think I think things are actually,
think things are getting in
a lot better place in it.
Just all in the media it seems like
they're not. Sometimes you know,
we'll take that.
That seemed like the not the fact that
someone's making a big deal out of that.
That's true.
You can't look,
you can't compare that to a bunch
of guys doing that to a girl.
It's not the same. It's not
devastating. The guy's going to be fine.
It is different. Men and women
are different. In that case.
That is a very clear cut case
of no one got hurt there.
Did they interrupt his broadcast?
Perhaps?
Did they ruin what he was trying
to say and I don't know what.
He might've had a serious message and
these caught Russian brides come over and
kiss him on the cheek.
Maybe they fucked up his little project
and what he's trying to accomplish. Yeah,
but there's no crime there. That's
not a crime. It's not the same.
If there was a bunch of dudes
doing that to a pretty girl,
some gorilla looking fucking football
player in her fucking corn Fed Iowa boys
came over and kissed her would be
like, Ooh, what are they doing?
You remember when they were trying to
make it a big deal because Katy Perry
kissed some guy on American
idol. Yes. Remember this is
like two months ago, right?
She kissed some boy and never
kissed a boy. She gets him.
She brought him over and kissed
him and there was like, oh,
well what if worth Katy Perry who was
a man? What if that was a girl? Yeah,
she's not stop.
She's Katy Perry.
And if that guy's really complained,
that Carrie Katy Perry, her kids are my,
I was still using my cares for
someone brought that to me, dude.
No one's going to love you.
Shut the fuck up.
If you can't appreciate Katy Perry
kissing you. Oh, she's pretty too,
was pretty. And more people will love
that man because Katy Perry kissed him.
Idol contestant shuts down Katy Perry.
Oh,
he shut down the Katy Perry backlash.
He kissed her to listen.
Nothing wrong with that. Looking
at, first of all, homeys gay, right?
Is He looking at him?
He could be from Idaho,
which she got shot him and he fell down.
That is not a male movie. That's not, oh,
he could be. Okay. It might
be that he's avoiding,
uh,
that kiss until he really did find the
woman that made him feel like you want,
wanted to be kissed. And maybe she stole
that from him. Yeah. See right there.
Right here.
Imagine if a 33 year old male artists
tricked in 19 year old female auditioner
do a kid like Katie pair. Well, imagine
that's a different thing. You fuck.
How about you?
Imagine that's a whole different thing.
I don't pretend to men and women
are the same. You fucking assholes.
Imagine a Volkswagen. Fuck your
stepmom. You know what I'm saying? Oh,
magic.
Now think about your dad does.
What are we doing? This is stupid.
It's just the same thing, man.
It's just fucking not the same thing.
Everybody's okay.
That Chinese guy was laughing, man. Oh,
he probably jerked off to the video.
The House multiple times.